(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
Look. Every generation
is the "What were you thinking?"
generation.
Doctors used to
do cigarette ads.
"A lung surgeon
needs steady hands."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Have you noticed that Trump,
unlike every other president,
did not age in office?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
We did!
Not that I would ever get work
done, not for any moral reason.
It's just, it doesn't work.
Now you just look old and weird.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
We have to find our way back
from not loathing each other.
Facebook.
Stop using it
to argue with some kid
you went to 3rd grade with
about Brett Kavanaugh!
People didn't use
to talk politics all the time
and they had no idea
how much they hated each other.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)